mr gardner um you've said in your
statement today
i've been liaising with our security
services for a number of years about
christine lee why was that were you
suspicious about her
i the first i knew about christine lee
being a spy
was this morning when i had a meeting
with the director of parliamentary
security and two
security service agents and they made me
aware that they now had information
which showed that christine lee had been
engaged in illegal activity um
but i had been cautious because i knew
that she was a solicitor who acted for a
number of chinese businesses in the uk
over a very long period of time and for
that reason i had spoken openly and
frankly with our security services for a
number of years
about the engagement that i had with her
and i made sure that at no time did they
suggest in any way that i should cut off
engagement with her
this morning
they made it clear that she had been
trying to
insinuate and influence across all
political parties here in parliament and
that they believed that she had been
doing this illegally and
as soon as i heard that after i finished
the meeting with the director of
security i then went and i immediately
contacted her son who has worked in my
office as the diary manager and i asked
him to tender his resignation forth with
which he did but i want to
stress to you that the security services
said to me that they had no information
that led them to believe that he was
aware of his mother's illegal activity a
lot of people will say you must have
known or if not you are very naive and
you said you had concerns you were
cautious was the word you used and yet
you carried on taking the money why why
not just if you were concerned you were
talking to the security services why not
say oh i don't think we should carry on
with this
i was cautious
but i was also transparent and at every
stage i registered quite properly
the donations that she had made to fund
the work of
researchers in my office
and i made it clear to the security
services what i was doing
the sources of that fund were
examined obviously they have to be and
they
were they were
perfectly bona fidi now um the security
services again today have advised me
that whilst they now have information
that suggests that some money that has
been given uh
through christine lee uh has not been
legitimate that does not relate to the
funding that went to pay for people in
my office but a lot of people also say
why were you taking money from a chinese
donor in the first place relations with
china are bad a lot of your
parliamentary colleagues would say
as the human rights record all sorts of
reasons why a british politician should
not be taking money from the chinese why
well the point is that she is not a
chinese donor and it would have been
illegal had she been a chinese donor for
me to take those those donations and
she's a british citizen uh she's a
british donor she's a qualified donor uh
and of course the work that uh those
people did in my office and which she
had no managerial control over no
control over the appointment of
that work was to the benefit of my
parliamentary work and to the benefit of
my constituents in brent north do you
not think that i mean i'm surprised that
the spooks the security services didn't
say mr gardner not sure you should be
associating yourself and taking money
from this person
and that's precisely why i had those
conversations with them and at no time
at no stage did they suggest that i
should do that are you prepared now to
open up all your financial records and
so on as some conservative mps are
saying are you prepared to be cooperate
with any sort of inquiry here because
clearly um it doesn't look good
sorry i i have always been transparent
uh about all the donations that have
been made to my office they're properly
registered they're properly recorded and
i'm totally transparent about that and i
always happy did you ever discuss labour
party policy whether i mean i recall you
were peter mandelson's pps at one stage
you were a minister under mr blair you
were a shadow minister energy i think
was one of your portfolios was it
business um
power stations all those sort of things
issues with the chinese and their
investments in uk power stations did you
discuss policy with her
no not in great detail no not in great
detail no absolutely not i had
conversations she must have got got
something out of it though i mean here
she is she's handing over all this money
i mean why was she doing it then if she
wasn't trying to find out what you were
up to as a labour front bencher well i i
think she must have felt it was a very
poor investment if she did
seek to get something out of it and
because i have been critical of the
chinese government on many many
occasions
in in fact i have criticized them most
recently probably at cop26 for the way
in which they uh they stopped the deal
uh to to uh power past coal to stop uh
coal investments i've been critical in
through the democracy forum which i
chair uh of their record on human rights
on the uyghurs i've criticized the belt
and road initiative that the the chinese
have put forward and the way in which
that has uh been spread throughout uh
the the uh
southeast asia and also through africa
so
if they if they were looking for
somebody who was compliant uh then they
will have not found it in me and that's
why it makes me really angry that they
sought
to have some sort of influence in that
way
and
i'm very angry about that
but i've always been absolutely clear
with our security services what the
relationship is but you you were a
supporter of chinese investment in
hinckley point weren't you a very con
controversial project
in fact you'll recall that uh when
hinckley point was reviewed under
theresa may
i was the person who said that the
british taxpayer and the british bill
pair was paying far too much uh for the
energy that we produced at tinkly point
and i said that the government should
reduce the tariffs so that the investors
china being one would not make as much
money and i also pointed out
that the reason the chinese wanted to be
there in
investing in hinckley point was so that
they could go around the world saying
look we have actually provided a nuclear
power station in one of the toughest
regimes in the world but you backed the
investment didn't you
i what i did was i said the government
should review the terms you were
probably a cheerleader for the project
no i wasn't a cheerleader for the
project certainly not and in fact i was
highly critical of the government at the
time and the way they were allowing the
investors to get away with ripping off
british bill payers
see people are going to say you've
either been duped you've been naive
you've been reckless or you've been
irresponsible here and you shouldn't
have taken money for what many people
will say is a tainted regime well
clearly i did not have any appreciation
and indeed the security services at the
moment have no evidence at all they've
told me that the money which i received
came from that regime that's the first
thing to say they are clear about that
and so am i um but of course i feel very
angry about it uh and i feel
deeply distressed that they should have
targeted me in that way as indeed they
targeted many other people but don't
forget this is this was a company which
received an award from for num from
number 10 uh for the uh christine lee
received an award for number 10 for the
work the good work that she was doing
within the community in britain so to
all intents and purposes i believe that
they had a green light to operate
nonetheless i was cautious and i made
sure that i cleared everything i did
with the security services nevertheless
over the years we've added it up it
comes to almost seven hundred thousand
pounds you've had from christine lee
that's more than owen patterson got from
randox
now i know nobody's i'm not suggesting
you were a paid advocate but it's an
awful lot of money so people will say
john doesn't look right you know very
well
that i did not benefit personally in any
way from any of those donations
those monies were paid directly to the
people who were employed
there was a contract in place
that ensured that there could be no
contamination i came nowhere near the
money and the politics they came nowhere
near that they had no role in the
appointment and they had no role in the
management of those staff so there was
that separation and that was really
important and that was a point that was
one of the steps that i put in place and
i was in consultation with the the
security services here in the uk to make
sure that there was no possibility of
contamination in that way when did you
last uh speak to christine lee um
earlier this week um
what was that conversation about and it
was it about this did you know this was
coming from the speaker absolutely not
the security services the first time
what did you speak about this week the
first i heard about it was today and
what we spoke about earlier this week um
was the
uh it was actually the the um
situation of my parents-in-law um
who are elderly and ill and she had
expressed concern as to to their
well-being and that's what we spoke
about in your statement you say she
ceased funding any workers in my office
in june 2020 yes and yet daniel wilkes
was still there until today
he was he was not funded uh by christine
lee he was funded as a normal contract
on ipsa he started off working in my
office as a volunteer
many years ago and the
the
when a position became available it was
openly advertised he applied for that
job as a volunteer as often happens in
parliament as you know and and he got
the job on merit so what exactly was all
this money for this very you'll
appreciate your constituents will say
this is an awful lot of money perhaps
more than we earn in a lifetime what was
it for
and from my point of view that money was
there to improve the work that i was
able to do in parliament and to improve
the work that i was able to do for my
constituents
it paid for those researchers and it
paid for them directly none of it none
of it was for my personal benefit
i don't think anybody's suggesting it
was your personal benefit but the fact
is it helped you run your office didn't
it yes and um but but that as you know
is the case with many many donors who
who fund researchers and workers in mp's
offices now i know that she also gave
money to sir ed davey before he was sir
ed when now the liberal democrat leader
and you've mentioned links with other
parties but
not many mps get all this amount of
money from a business person who's got
links with china i come back to the
point about china human rights and so on
some british mps have been sanctioned as
the word they used by the chinese
authorities i come back to the point it
looks terrible
well um
this is somebody who received awards
from the british prime minister this is
somebody who to all intents and purposes
was operating as a legitimate person in
the uk
it now is clear because the security
services have uncovered this information
and that
she was acting to try and gain influence
i am very clear and i believe the
security services are clear that she did
not manage to do that she gained no
political advantage for the chinese
state from me in any way whatsoever do
you regret what you've done do you feel
a fool no i don't feel a fool but i do
feel very angry and i feel very angry
that somebody tried to use me in that
way